foreign
the original idea behind
cryptocurrencies included
decentralization as a major component
this required a method of transaction
confirmation independent of financial
institutions and this is where proof of
work originated as a response to this
problem proof of work is used to secure
the Integrity of new data on the
decentralized networks used by
cryptocurrencies and other defy apps but
this much information is not enough so
here I am to take you through this new
video of Simply learn on proof of work
that will give you all the necessary and
interesting information to understand
this concept in depth so without further
Ado let's get started with the video
first let's have a quick look at the
topics that we're going to cover in this
video first we will understand
blockchain's consensus method following
that we will understand what proof of
work is in detail moving on we will
explore how proof of work and Mining
work together followed by an example of
proof of work functioning then we will
look into some of the pros and cons of
proof of work after which we will have a
crisp comparison between proof of work
and proof of stake then we will come
across cryptocurrencies using proof of
work and finally we will see what
criticism it's facing nowadays so let's
begin our journey through this video but
before that do like this video and hit
the Bell icon never to miss an update
from Simply learn so first we will
understand blockchains consensus method
the foundation and integrity of all
cryptocurrency blockchains are consensus
mechanisms before delving into the
various consensus processes we must
first Define what it means for
blockchains to reach consensus a
collection of peers or nodes in a
network decides which blockchain
transactions are valid and which are not
through a consensus process
methodologies that Foster consensus are
employed to realize this Accord these
guidelines Aid in guarding networks
against bad behavior and hacker attacks
depending on the blockchain and its use
numerous distinct kinds of consensus
processes exist and while they vary in
energy consumption security and
scalability they all serve the same
function of ensuring that records are
accurate and truthful and proof of work
is one of the most used consensus
mechanisms but this raises the question
of what proof of work is
so proof of work or pow refers to a
mechanism that discourages pointless or
harmful uses of computing resources such
as altering any data stored in a
blockchain network by requiring a not
insignificant but doable amount of
effort though there are several scaling
difficulties it is usually considered to
be the most dependable and safe of all
the consensus systems in pow users
compete against one another to use
powerful computers to solve extremely
difficult computational puzzles and this
process is known as mining the first
person to generate the 64-digit hash
gains the privilege of creating a new
block validating transactions and
earning a fixed sum of cryptocurrency
referred to as a block reward
let's understand the concept of proof of
work and Mining in detail
consider there are two friends Sarah and
Ian who have a conventional bank account
in a bank
Sarah was supposed to pay Ian her share
of one hundred dollars for a party so
she gives him a check for one hundred
dollars once the check is deposited in
the bank Sarah starts wondering if the
exact amount in the check will only get
debited from her account or if some
extra charges will be there and Ian on
the other side is also wondering if the
exact 100 will be credited to his
account or if there will be hidden
charges both parties involved in the
transaction must have faith in the bank
to transfer money correctly for the bank
to be considered valuable there are no
financial institutions or Bankers to
guarantee trust in cryptocurrencies
rather using Miners and proof of work
ensures accurate and transparent
transactions miners are the stewards and
facilitators that keep the system secure
and correct for blockchains that employ
proof of work now the proof of work
mechanism necessitates Miner's use of
computational power in exchange for the
right to mine here's how it works
Step One is grouping new transactions
together in this step users purchase and
sell cryptocurrencies and the
information resulting from these
transactions is combined into a block
then comes step two in this crypto
miners compete to be the first to solve
a difficult mathematical problem then
the miner earns the privilege to execute
the block of transactions by providing
evidence that they have performed the
Computing work known as a hash and then
comes step three in which one minor is
chosen to add the new block whoever gets
the opportunity to process the block is
chosen at random to some extent and then
the winner receives brand new crypto
coins and creates a new blockchain block
there are challenging issues that call
for a lot of computational effort
because miners have spent a lot of money
on the necessary computer hardware and
energy they are incentivized to
authenticate transactions precisely
let's have a look at an example of this
consensus method a computer must
randomly perform hashing operations
until it generates an output with the
required minimum number of leading zeros
to provide proof of work for example the
hash for block number
123456 mined on August 6 2022 is
and the block reward for that successful
hash was 6.25 BTC that block will always
have the header of the previous block
and 745 transactions totaling slightly
over 1 666 Bitcoins the generated hash
would be unrecognizable if someone
attempted to alter a transaction amount
by even one crypto coin and the network
would reject the fraud attempt
completely now that we know the complete
mechanism behind proof of work and it's
working let's look at some of its pros
and cons
first proof of work has no bias block
incentives let you move from having no
crypto to having a positive balance and
you can start without any crypto at all
but proof of work is harmful to the
environment because it consumes a lot of
energy second proof of work is a tested
consensus method that is long maintained
the security and decentralization of
Bitcoin and ethereum still mine related
equipment is so sophisticated that it
requires a significant initial
investment
third it is more straightforward to
implement than proof of stake but as
computational requirements rise mining
pools may come to dominate the industry
posing problems of centralization and
security Now that we know its strengths
and weaknesses let's compare it with
today's tough competition of proof of
work which is proof of stake
at its core proof of stake and proof of
work seek to secure consensus within the
decentralized network however there are
some variations in the personnel and
method first proof of stake is more
scalable than proof of work since it
requires significantly less
computational power proof of state
cryptocurrencies are more ecologically
friendly since they possess transactions
more quickly for lower costs and with
less energy
second the blockchain is updated using
both techniques after validating
incoming transactions in proof of stake
Network users are referred to as
validators rather than miners the fact
that validators lock up specific
quantities of cryptocurrency their stake
in a smart contract on the blockchain
rather than solving mathematical
equations is the significant distinction
as proof of work does
third from a security standpoint proof
of work is more established parties with
significant crypto Holdings might have
too much Authority which is a potential
issue with proof of stake but not with
proof of work
so now that we have covered all the
necessary details about proof of work
let's look at some of the top cryptos
that use this mechanism
Bitcoin in 2009 the first cryptocurrency
Bitcoin was introduced it established
the idea of proof of work in
cryptocurrencies which numerous other
coins would subsequently Embrace next is
Bitcoin cash a cryptocurrency called
Bitcoin cash is a fork of the original
Bitcoin a spin-off or alternative
cryptocurrency called Bitcoin cash was
developed in 2017. next is Monero the
cryptocurrency Monero is decentralized
it obfuscates transactions using a
public distributed Ledger and privacy
enhancing technology to achieve
fungibility and anonymity then we have
Litecoin one of the first alternative
currencies to bitcoin or altcoins was
Litecoin it was introduced in 2011 and
provided faster transaction speeds
thanks to its use of the Bitcoin source
code
and finally we have Dogecoin based on
the doge meme Dogecoin is a
cryptocurrency introduced in 2013.
despite its light-hearted beginning it
would eventually develop a devoted fan
base with time proof of work has also
faced some challenges and criticism for
its outdated mechanism which are the
most pointed out ones energy consumption
the New York Times claims that in 2009
one Bitcoin could be mined with a
standard desktop computer and very
little electricity but to mine one
Bitcoin in today's era one would have
needed to utilize as much electricity as
a typical American Home would in nine
years
centralization
decentralization is one of the key
benefits that attract crypto investors
however because of the high
computational and energy requirements of
proof of work mining operations have
been concentrated in a select few large
companies and this might lead to a few
companies controlling most of the
cryptocurrency business
well this was all about proof of work
and this brings us to the end of this
video I hope you found this video
informative and interesting if you like
this video then please hit the like
button and subscribe to our YouTube
channel simply learn for more
interesting videos like this if you have
any questions regarding the video please
feel free to ask away in our comments
section our team will reach out to you
as soon as possible
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here